we've got the presidents acting
department homeland security secretary
with us right now Chad Wolfe earlier you
might have seen at this big event on
coming up with a vaccine a marshal plan
to come up with a vaccine where the
president indicated his goal was to have
it by the end of the year of very
aggressive because the administration's
being very aggressive on reports that
China is trying to hack into these
research efforts and steal of all of
this the acting secretary with us now
Chad Wolf's secretary thank you for
taking the time I know you are looking
very closely at trying to get on top of
this what do we know about what Chinese
hackers might be doing to sort of steal
this stuff well thanks Neil for having
me on what our cyber security and
infrastructure security agency along
with the FBI did this week is to put out
an advisory making sure that individuals
when it comes to kovin 19 research
understand that we have some bad actors
China specifically cyber actors also
some non-traditional actors such as
journalists and other researchers that
are targeting our intellectual property
when it comes to that research targeting
individuals such as our own researchers
when it comes to this so we wanted to
maintain some awareness on this so that
they so that our us community-based
researchers could understand what is
going on our health care industry could
understand what's going on this is very
similar to what we did back in a couple
of months ago again with DHS we put out
an alert with our UK counterparts where
we said we may have malicious cyber
actors again targeting international
health organizations and I think overall
what we've seen nil is as this pandemic
has gone on and on we see more targeting
of our healthcare industry and
specifically when it comes to China it's
this isn't a surprise we know that China
for a very long time have been have been
very bad actors in the cyber space so
this isn't news to us but we need to
stay on it we need to stay engaged with
our other partners in the United States
government make sure that our private
sector partners the healthcare industry
and others are aware of this and have
their shields up as well
so a ticket of what you're saying
secretary that they are not only trying
to hack and get that information but but
take it for themselves right in other
words to use this and advance their own
possible remedies vaccines anything that
might deal with this and and and find a
cure for this yes that's exactly right I
think what they're targeting again is
not only the intellectual property that
that we're creating here again when we
talk about kovat 19 research but again
targeting our personnel to steal that
information so that they can be at the
at the cutting edge of that research and
we need to make sure that that's
protected and that's part of what we do
from a cyber perspective at the
Department of Homeland Security and
again working with our partners at the
FBI to investigate that and then
prosecute when appropriate now in the me
know the administration you particularly
serve been involved in trying to
restrict the foreign immigration as this
elevated to the point of targeting
Chinese students who want to want to
study here be here even those on you
know two-year plans where they're
learning beyond just college material
stuff I mean it seems to go a little
wider than that it does and again from a
department perspective we're looking at
there's a number of visas that Chinese
students Chinese researchers and others
utilize we're taking a look at how we
address the fraud that we all know is in
that system and I think that takes on
special importance here as we come out
of this pandemic as we look to restart
the economy making sure that we have
jobs available to Americans to integrate
them back into the workforce so we're
happy to bring the breasts and the
brightest into the US but we need to
make sure that we reserve those jobs at
least here initially so that we can have
US workers again get back in that
workforce regain their livelihood and
participate so there are some student
visas that we are taking a look at we
know that there's fraud there's abuse in
the program and it's time that we deal
with that what about Chinese students
who just come to study
here are you cracking down on that those
are already here for studies not a lot
of them Stein meat of course because of
the virus and the fact that classes are
virtually virtual everywhere but that
that you want to tamp this down come the
fall well we're certainly taking a look
at that and there are a number of
individuals both here and and overseas
looking to come in as well and I think
from again from a DHS perspective making
sure that we can ensure that they are
are coming here to the US for the right
reasons
they're here to study they're not here
to do other nefarious things so we're
doing that again in partnership with
other law enforcement agencies inside
the US government and I think that's
important I will also say the Department
took some other action earlier this week
when we looked at Chinese journalists
that are again coming here under a
certain visa was throughout the duration
of their stay so in many cases that was
years and years and years utilizing that
visa for other purposes perhaps doing
things that again were not not correct
so what we did is we tapped down on that
and said you can stay here for 90 days
at a time you can come back you can get
that reassessed but you're going to have
to do an interview with DHS and we're
gonna we're gonna ask some hard
questions so I think this is part of an
overall effort to make sure that again
we're looking closely at these
individuals that we're not getting in
them blanket visas for years at a time
and again that's to make sure that we
protect the American people well watch
it very closely Chad Wolfe thank you
very much the acting DHS secretary
joining us out of watching